[Music]
hey what is up guys I'm qHD here and
this is the Galaxy Note 5 so the latest
and greatest from the big smartphone
lineup from Samsung so with this latest
in the note series most of the biggest
changes and most of the new stuff with
this phone is just on the outside its
with the new design language the new
look of the hardware and just how
different it looks and feels than the
last note we now have an all metal and
glass phone on the outside so chamfered
metal rails on the sides of the phone
and 10 of bands on the top and the
bottom and curved all glass back that's
both much prettier but also potentially
much uglier when you inevitably get a
bunch of fingerprints on it
this thing is a fingerprint magnet it's
available in four colors sapphire
blueish the gold a white and my personal
favorite the titanium gray since it
shows the least fingerprints and you're
probably noticing it's taken a lot of
this design language from its little
brother of the galaxy s6 so steel back
no removable or expandable anything thin
metal edges to hold on to and now with
its larger size
I think the galaxy note 5 takes a crown
for the slipperiest phone of all time
both in the hand and in the pocket I
swear it's slipped out of my pocket in
cars more than any other phone and it's
like a bar so sometimes trying to pick
it up it's crazy this is definitely one
of those phones where you're probably
gonna want to change the texture on the
back to make it easier to hold or to
hide fingerprints so a lot of people
might think about buying a case for the
zone but it's already such a big phone
that you probably don't want it to be
even bigger in the hand so the easiest
way to change the texture but without
adding bulk would be a skin I'll leave a
link to the skins that I like to use
from deep brand right below that like
button you can pick both the texture and
a new color if you want but yeah so this
is the look of a samsung flagship now
shiny glossy and ultimately more premium
looking I also like that they kept
working on footprint so the Galaxy Note
5 is actually a bit smaller than the
note 4 thanks to a very thin side bezel
and other things like you know the
headphone jack placement and the
fingerprint sensor and the buttons are
all excellent the buttons like the
galaxy s6 are super clicky and tactile
and satisfying and easy to press there
are definitely still constant this new
design though one there's no IR blaster
anymore not sure why I didn't really use
the one on the note 4 a ton but it was
nice to have but then 2 & 3 a
non-removable battery and no expandable
storage these two things only feel like
such a big deal because of the natural
comparison to the predecessor the Galaxy
Note 4 which had a larger removable
battery and a microSD card slot so it
kind of feels like you're losing
features while moving up a generation
the expandable storage isn't a huge deal
to me because I can work with 32 gigs
but if you want to take your music
collection offline or if you take a lot
of 4k video then you'll probably start
to fill it up pretty quick and I'll talk
about the battery life more in a bit the
speaker at the bottom when you're not
blocking it
he is loud and fairly impressive but I
hold my phone like this and I sometimes
block the speaker and when I
accidentally do it's actually amazing
how much it suffers obviously you'll
know immediately when you're blocking it
but it's almost comical how pretty much
you can mute the speaker by putting a
finger tip over the speaker grille since
it's so small
[Music]
anyway on the front of this phone the
note 5 is rocking a 5.7 inch 2560 by
1440 Super AMOLED display so an awesome
quad HD resolution super sharp pixel
density excellent brightness to the
point where it's plenty readable
outdoors great viewing angles really
saturated but adjustable colors and
spans pretty much to the edges of the
phone with the super thin bezels it is
the best display on any smartphone right
now so if you like screens then so
having such a great display has always
been it like a strong point for the
Galaxy Note and that's no exception here
and the specs inside push all those
pixels just fine
in fact the galaxy note 5 is again a
beast in the spec department bringing up
a lot of the top hardware from the
galaxy s6 and it pretty much checks all
the boxes so octa-core exynos 7420 chip
a bump up to 4 gigabytes of RAM the 16
megapixel camera from the galaxy s6 that
was so good with optical image
stabilization and an F 1.9 aperture NFC
AC Wi-Fi LTE advanced the whole package
the only specs that may look like a
downgrade on paper are the move from
that weird USB 3 port back to the USB
2.0 on the bottom and the smaller 3000
milliamp hour battery it may sound weird
to say that a 3000 milliamp hour battery
is small but for such a high powered
device and such a big bright high res
display kind of expected more my battery
life on the galaxy note 5 was pretty
decent not great it was a lot better
than the galaxy s6 which was abysmal but
I would give this I rated it somewhere
between three and a half to four hours
of screen on time sometimes more which
to my use for a phone like this is a
beat now sammy is trying to make up for
that non removable battery with wireless
charging which is much faster than
before and fast charging which is super
awesome on this phone so if I'm about to
head out and I found myself with low
battery I can legit plug in for like 10
minutes and have significantly more
power before I head out now obviously
this isn't a hundred percent solution
for a sealed in battery but it's a
pretty damn good one and I'm usually
around a power source so I can plug in
whether I'm at home or in my car or
something so I am a fan of fast charging
now pretty much the rest of this phone
is a scaled up version of the galaxy s6
experience it's the latest version of
TouchWiz on top of android 5.1
and it's still a pretty good performer
in the same way as the s6 you can grab a
theme from the theme store to make it
look more or less like stock Android if
you want to and you still have all the
samsung apps pre-installed stuff like s
health to measure your heart rate and
fitness if you want all the other s apps
s voice s note and then it has the
software features that are unique to the
note so the multi window on a larger
display it's still great it works with a
bunch of apps still not 100%
compatibility but it is helpful if you
want to multitask and get two things
done at the same time and then of course
you can't forget the stylus or S Pen now
you might be thinking hey wait that's
weird how do I get it out of the phone
if it's embedded like this well Samsung
built in a clicking mechanism in the pen
for getting it out a side effect though
that clicking mechanism being so good
doesn't actually do anything it's just
kind of addicting now every year I give
the new Galaxy Note a shot and with that
we get an improved s-pen every time so I
try to give that a shot but I always
just end up using it the same way which
is just like my finger just like a more
precise version of it since the tip is
smaller if you are an avid s-pen user
you will notice stuff like is improved
the menu when pulling out of the stylus
is updated and the functionality is
improved things like the s memos you can
pin any note to a home screen now which
is pretty dope something you couldn't do
before and there's also a new feature in
screen right called scroll capture so if
you want to take a screenshot of
something that's more than one page say
a multi-page document or a tall webpage
or something like that instead of taking
multiple screenshots and then having to
share them all you can use scroll
capture to merge them all into one huge
tall screenshot which is actually pretty
convenient and my favorite new s-pen
feature is the most convenient when the
screen is off you can pull out the S Pen
and immediately start writing on the
screen sort of like taking a pen and a
notepad out of your pocket and using a
to take a quick note and then when you
put the pen back in it automatically
saves whatever you just wrote which is
very handy for remembering quick things
for later also side note you may have
heard about the little problem where if
you slide the S Pen in backwards
it breaks so don't put it in that way
that's what she said so look if you can
get past a slippery hugeness of this
phone it's pretty hard to go wrong here
my favorite two features are the display
and the camera the display right now
like I said is the best on any
smartphone and the camera right now is
also arguably the best on any available
smartphone here are some shots I took in
my few weeks using the note 5 as a daily
driver just casual snaps obviously
optical image stabilization and some
sharpening and post-production makes for
some of the crispiest smartphone photos
of all time even in low-light
I could take handheld shots with a slow
shutter speed and still get crispy stuff
out of auto mode it does have a pro mode
if you're feeling like digging into it
but for the most part people use our
smartphone cameras in Auto and the note
5 is great at that the one other
smartphone I think that might come close
to the note 5 in terms of image quality
is the LG g4 in manual mode but the note
5 does in 2 seconds in Auto what could
take anyone else
ten seconds fiddling in manual mode so
you got to hand it to Samsung for that
so yeah there you have it that's the
note 5 the seal back and the smaller
battery kind of make it feel less like a
power users dream phone that we had in
previous notes and more like a bigger
version of they're already kind of big
premium flagship the galaxy s6 that's
why I'm calling it the galaxy s6 plus
not that there's anything wrong with
that it's still a pleasure to use and an
absolute killer on the spec sheet but
yeah it's just a new different direction
for the note series but it's still
absolutely the best phone that Samsung
makes right now thanks for watching and
I'll talk to you guys in the next one
peace